oh my gosh you guys that finale was
absolutely phenomenal elena it was
shocking to see julia's like harrowing
turn of events what was your reaction
when you read those final few pages when
you first got the script
it was really incredible because
you know both reading it and then
playing it
being able to
be weaved into the cathedral sequence
which is the most iconic visually of the
whole anime you know when spike falls to
the glass and to be the other
the person on the other side of that
holding a gun i just thought that was so
clever
and um and so that i mean it's
it was mind-blowing and it was just it
was
it was wonderful and i i just love the
finale so much and i couldn't wait to
get there i couldn't wait to put on the
costume i couldn't wait for it for any
of it so i'm just i'm just so pleased
i love it because i feel like it's gonna
for those who love the original project
so much this is really gonna keep them
on their toes like they're not going to
expect this alex what were your thoughts
when you saw how they kind of tweaked
things versus from the original i loved
it yeah i think it's really important to
to
flesh out particularly uh julia and her
sort of growth to a place of strength
and agency is such an important story to
tell especially coming out of such a
heavy relationship um
that is obviously so abusive and so
painful for her to kind of find that
space to take power and i just as an
audience member want to know what's
going to happen um me too
[Laughter]
oh my gosh well which cowboy bebop
easter egg are you most excited for the
fans to discover along the way
any come to mind we sort of um haven't
been let in yeah they're sort of secret
to us as well i think we have to have a
really keen eye looking around the set
and uh i think we're going to have to
find out as fans of it watching it
ourselves i'm going to be on a hunt for
sure you know because we you know we
never get to work with the other three
pretty much so
you know so we're definitely going to be
looking out for some stuff i know they
have a lot i was excited to see um
cowboy andy's uh name on the roster of
uh bounty hunters so i i'd like to see a
cowboy andy um i love cowboy andy he's
one of my favorite characters
alex as someone who has lived and
breathed and walked in vicious shoes
how do you feel about the fact that he's
now going to be playing perpetual rounds
of russian roulette with his former lady
love
yeah i mean that's a great ending isn't
it i mean i i have no idea i've no idea
what's going to happen um i i think
their relationship is probably done
i'm not sure
um season if there is a season two it's
um basically like in treatment where
they're just uh
they're just in couples therapy
um but i think that would be an
expensive bill
well okay dream with me i really want a
season two i'm keeping my fingers
crossed is there anything on your dream
list your bucket list that you would
love to see for both your characters if
we do get a second season they're both
alive so we got a good start right there
i really really really want a scene with
faye uh the scene in the red corvette
when we're you know when they're um
being chased and the shootout i just
think i mean that's such a cool scene um
and i i really really hope we get to do
that and i finally want to work with you
know danny and mustafa i you know we we
didn't i mean i don't know about you but
i didn't get to work with either of them
at all so i i really want to
to explore the back story um of the war
in titan with uh
mason gren uh the character of gren i
think that'd be that'd be really cool to
have a backstory there that'd be awesome
oh my gosh all right well i've got a
very serious question for you guys let's
talk about the bestest good boy in the
galaxy
my ein
oh what like obviously you guys didn't
get to share too many scenes with him
but he was around on set what is
something that you think fans would be
surprised to know about the good boy who
brings iron to our lives
i've heard ein was very difficult
yeah he um was the most demanding you
couldn't look him in the eye yeah um you
know you weren't allowed to talk to him
uh
no i i we had no no absolutely no
interactions with iron and i was very
upset about it can't you know can't
there be an episode where you know we
just have them over for dinner or
something and they bring the dog they
still want to play with the dog
uh but maybe season two yeah maybe maybe
ein comes into
the basement and it's like vicious pet
um your emotional support
exactly
oh my gosh alex i'm curious what was the
wig process like for you
yeah well it got shorter as we you know
got used to it it's always fun to look
really different um and obviously it's
such an iconic part of the uh the anime
i remember there were very very brief
discussions earlier on early on as to
whether or not you know he should have
this
mane and it was like of course of course
he should um yeah so it's great fun i
mean there was a brief moment of the
first time i had to really fight and i
did a spin and a roll or something and
it was all just sort of you know in
front of my eyes and i couldn't see
where i was swinging the sword but um i
got used to that and there were no
accidents
oh okay okay
um and then elena i've just gotta give
you so many props for the penultimate
episode when we finally hear julia sing
it's just haunting and beautiful what
was it like for you filming that scene
were you nervous like break it down for
me
so the jitters when they when they show
the side stage shot of julia and she's
like you know
those were so real i was so nervous i
mean that was a bar full of people
and that was me singing and so it was
just
i was terrified that every bit of that
was real jitters real emotion and i
remember when we
finished the first wide shot i was just
this
like
exhilarating can we do it a hundred
times more
it was really a lot of fun